et puis comme chaque soir un autre
regard sur la politique nous enquête
dans les circonscriptions hier soir nous
étions en outre mer avec bernard
pradines au reste on y met de guadeloupe
nous passons en guyane là bas on se sent
encore plus éloigné de la métropole et
donc peut-être un peu moins concernés
par le scrutin des 12 et 19 mars
résultat une tendance marquée à
l'abstention
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
joveneau comme chaque soir à la
politique intérieure malgré la fin de la
semaine à 6000 km de paris yves rambo
journalistes avaient faire 3 parle de
politique exactement comme s'ils étaient
en métropole
georges marchais continue lui a attaqué
de toute part il a proposé à françois
mitterrand néanmoins une nouvelle
rencontre il est peu probable que la
réponse du parti socialiste sera
positive à l'examen l'impact des
informations est typiquement parisienne
est très faible en guyane pour un
département grand comme la bretagne on
ne compte que 50 5000 habitants et 22
mille électeurs la guyane nelly qu'un
seul député
c'est le même depuis 67 monsieur rivière
est beau liste contre lui lui mois
prochain un seul candidat de poids un
socialiste madame et monsieur à risque
elle est employée de banque il est
infirmier représente un couple
d'électeurs moyens pas très motivé il
est vrai que l'assemblée nationale est
bien loin
- des merveilles en fait 400 sur place
et puis surtout très loin du pays qu'ils
ont vite oublié je ne sais pas
savoir dire
non et il est très rare qu'ils tiennent
leurs promesses bonjour et alors quand
ça a débuté nous avait promis un train
très anglaise ça nous servira
comme argument électoral n'est pas
malade aurait fait de nous proposer des
écoles des centres d'apprentissage
pour moi c'était voilà mais
ça nous emmène
madame kalima qui est indienne vite avec
toute sa famille près de cayenne elle
est plus que sceptique et fait partie
des 50% des électeurs guyanais qui
s'abstiennent de voter allez voter pour
le député
pourquoi vous ne votez pas
ça vous intéresse pas ou n'avaient pas
confiance dans la politique oui et sa
confidente
et vous qu'est ce que vous faites là
tous les jours
connaissant très jolie d'ailleurs
à l'est et les jeunes gens ça les
intéresse vos enfants vos petits enfants
vous par exemple avec l âge n 2 on avait
le droit sauter par conséquent oui elle
est intéressante et verts n'ont jamais
ce qui préoccupe les guyanais ce sont
les prix
tout ou presque vient de la métropole et
le coût du transport fait augmenter
considérablement le prix du kilo de
pommes de terre
le gouvernement actuellement dépensent
des sommes énormes pour
indemniser les fonctionnaires sous
prétexte que la vie est chère
si on disposait de cette masse
l'argent ce supplément de salaire pour
financer le transport des marchandises
qui grève considérablement leur prix est
bien le problème serait résolu il y
aurait à ce grand pays de vie chère on
vendrait pratiquement tous même prix
qu'en france et c'est d'une proposition
qui est faite par les partis ou les
candidats politiques aux élections ici
écoutez je n'en n'ai pas connaissance
pour ce que j'avais tous les gens qui
tentent dans la politique ils sont
intéressés
à ce problème là ensemble est
précisément fonctionnaires plus ou moins
m
élections le mois prochain mais d'abord
le carnaval la fête traditionnelle à
laquelle tout le pays y participent y
compris les grands de la politique dans
une danse beaucoup plus fraternel qui
respectueuse